[Music]
hi everyone my name is Nick butcher I'm
a designer and engineer at Google and
I'm also a vector addict and I've got
five minutes to tell you some of about
some of the advanced features at vector
drawables androids vector format
supports so let's get started so I put
it that most assets in your applications
should be vectors these days vectors are
awesome they're sharp on every single
density display and they're very small
the compress well so they don't blow
your apk but they're also extremely
flexible and I want to talk about this a
bit today so you can get the most out of
vectors too and realize these benefits
as widely as possible so most vectors in
your app probably look something like
this they have some parts and they're
probably hard coding a color and
something like this fill or stroke here
maybe you're using a color resource like
this and but there's actually a lot more
you can do here which I want to talk
about and the first thing is using theme
colors so you can use team colors in two
ways really the first is by applying a
theme color as a tint and this will tint
the entire drawable and based on the
current theme so here I'm using the
theme attribute color control normal
which is the normal color for icons and
as search you can have one single asset
which displays in different themes say a
like screen or a dark screen and it gets
tinted to be the right color you've no
longer have to worry what color asset
you got from your designers in the SVG
and that they got exactly the right
shade of gray that you need and it'll be
tinted at runtime so is always correct
you can also use theme colors and
directly in the fill or stroke so in
this example here I'm going to use color
primary so say you have different
screens in your app like say a sports
app which uses a theme for a given team
you can reference that theme color so
you can have a single drawable which
just parts of it get colored based on
the theme which can be useful cool
little swim colors next up close state
lists so vector support and pressing
close state lists you can do some fun
stuff so in this example and on press
state we're changing color or perhaps
you have a list app and where when a row
item is selected you could have changed
the rendering using and using that state
you could do this with a normal
stateless drawable and to drawables and
flip between them but if say the
rendering is like 99% the same you just
want to change like the stroke here this
saves some duplication and you define it
like this like a regular color state
list in your
and colored resources and refer to it as
you would like a color resource unless
my favorite feature is gradients and so
vectors support three different types of
gradients a linear radial and sweep
which you define like this so a linear
gradient has a start and end XY
coordinates a radial has a center and a
radius and a sweep just has a center
point I've so far been using the
shorthand of start and or even center
colors to define gradients you can
actually get much more fine-grained and
embed these item tags inside it to
define individual color stops so here
I'm going for a specific color at 72% of
the way through like let's let lets you
define gradients in a color resource
directory or you can use the inline
resource syntax to embed it inside the
vector definition itself and at Build
time a apt will actually extract that to
a color resource and insert a reference
to it for you which is handy
so who agents have been super handy in
building apps like here's an
illustration from a former year's i/o
app which if we've made it as a gradient
would be with gradient support would
have been one-fifth the size of the
brass that we had to ship and sharp
everywhere it's really useful for things
like adaptive like ones because
unfortunate vectors don't support and
drop shadows but you can fake it a lot
of the time using gradients all you need
to build something like a customized
spinner this is really trivial to
achieve using a radial gradient so
gradients only support and certain
shapes like this linear radial and sweet
but and passed in vectors can be
transformed like rotated and so on and
so in this example I wanted to create
this oval-shaped shadow belief that
beneath the jetpack Droid and so I did
this by just drawing a circle and with a
radial gradient and then using the scale
Y feature to transform it to produce the
effect that I was after if the gradient
you define doesn't fill the entire shape
you're drawing too you can use the tile
mode to control how it fills the rest of
the area so in this example and the
default mode of clamp it just continues
the color outwards if you use a repeat
mode it will repeat between the grading
going back and continuing it or a mirror
mode will go back and forth through the
gradient you can also use gradients
which don't go through different colors
so by using the same color between two
stops and having the next stop start at
the same point you'd have these solid
solid color blocks like why would you
want a gradient it doesn't do that well
you can have some fun with some pretty
cool effects so this example of a
rainbow is one
single shape using a radial gradient
with these sort of color stops you can
do like something like a loading spinner
or you can combine it with the tile mode
to make some kind of pattern support so
this is the gradient over this area and
the part of the tile mode repeats it to
give you a pattern and you can have some
fun doing something like animating it
and produce this kind of loading effect
so hopefully I've shown you the vectors
are sharp small and extremely flexible
so you can use them everywhere there's a
final example I want to show you what
you can build this is a single and
animated vector drawable drawn by and
the amazing Virginia of pole track and I
had the pleasure of animating it so this
is like one vector drawable extremely
small extremely sharp and every display
you can have some fun with them so
that's vector drawables thanks very much
[Music]